so we got this story from KRON4 San
Francisco mandates proof of full covet
vaccine at indoor venues I love this
title indoor venues because it's not the
truth they actually explain in the art
in the article it's not indoor venues
what's a venue a venue is a forum that's
like a public forum but when you say
venue you're thinking like a bar or a
theater or a concert you're not thinking
a cafe unless the cafe is a small stage
I guess but they actually go on to say
that it is it is more than just venues
it's restaurants cafes bars gyms hmm
mayor London breed announced Thursday
during a press conference
I don't see uh the vaccine passport
ultimately is the end is is going to be
the end result whether it's intentional
or not it's going to be that you will
have to show your papers wherever you go
it's funny that this is literally
showing your papers and we we have
a historical look at the fascists
regimes the Nazis and why showing your
papers was frowned upon the idea that
you couldn't move about and freely
associate without some kind of idea and
now you have what's what's the meme the
the the punch punching Nazi people had a
really quick 180 to show us your papers
or something like that or or a glare an
alarmingly an alarming number of punch
and Nazi people are now saying show us
your papers this is it and they'll start
with something like this but it's just
about keeping people safe with the
vaccines that's my issue with this that
it's all based on a false premise uh the
CDC director Rachelle wilenski admitted
it uh about uh two weeks ago she
admitted that the vaccines so-called do
not prevent transmission of the Delta
variant for example and right now we're
seeing a spike in the Delta variant but
the mortality rates are low and the
hospitalizations are being
misrepresented but still it's so really
low the specific issue there is they're
saying uh the vaccine will reduce your
likelihood to get it but the CDC also
says viral load and those with
breakthrough cases are the same as those
who are unvaccinated the bigger problem
I suppose is animal repositories yes of
course
we've seen all the stories about dogs
and cats getting covered and if that's
the case and it can transfer back I'm
not sure I'm not gonna pretend to be a
doctor because I don't know then that
would be alarming I'm not you know we're
not vaccinating our pets so ultimately
I'll say this and I always do I don't
give medical advice I'm not here to
discourage or encourage anybody you talk
to a doctor make sure you're doing it
right by you there was a story the other
day about this nurse in Germany who
swapped out people's vaccines for Saline
and that to me is a violation of
informed consent and psychotic if an
elderly person wants to get medication
their doctor recommends it no one should
be doing that that's crazy but my bigger
issue is hey men if you go to your
doctor and your doctor says here's the
medicine I prescribed to you
I go to the doctor the doctor says okay
I shouldn't have to go to to get get
tested for something or then go to a
venue and show them my medical ID
because it's going to go beyond that
this right now it's how they get you
they say well we want to stop the
pandemic you got to get the app you got
to get the Excelsior pass and in a year
I tell you it's going to be something
else it's going to be oh did you uh oh
you said naughty words it's going to be
total social credit it was funny I
tweeted this I tweeted social credit
scores are next and some some like
establishment lefties are like you watch
too much TV I thought it was funny I was
like yeah you know I maybe because I
watched a documentary from the German
Outlet DW and uh they interviewed some
Chinese individuals working on the
social credit stuff talking about how
amazing it was and how crime has gone
down and it's and it's so amazing now
that people are recognizing that you
can't just do these things like oh yeah
putting people in rigid boxes the
biggest problem I have with it
centralized Authority doesn't work it
spins out spins out of control the scent
emerges rapidly and because of this
centralized control and and people being
pressed down there's no pressure release
for the people right there's no protest
there's no leave there's there's no
moment of of being left alone and that's
one of the things I said a year or so
two years ago maybe I said they will
never leave you alone if you think
keeping your head down is going to keep
you out of this political conflict you
are wrong and the best thing you can do
now is speak up before it's too late
unfortunately people don't care it's a
sad it's a sad tale man we have how many
stories from the past about
totalitarians authoritarians and why you
must speak up
but I didn't speak up because I wasn't X
or I wasn't Y and I don't want I don't
want to lose my job because you know I
have kids
I said this over the past couple of
years speak up at your job when they do
the critical rights applied principle
stuff speak up against it stand up
against it and people say but I'll get
fired think about the future for your
kids and they say well you know okay
well now you're at the point where your
job is mandating uh either masks or
vaccines and we get people commenting
being like what do I do and I'm like you
could have stood up last year you know
and pushed back against the
authoritarian you know takeover but for
now I would just recommend first going
to your doctor and making your decision
on your own health and then if you if
you can't work at this place for
whatever reason leave the job yeah and I
think what we're seeing right now is
that a bunch of the elitists who are at
the Forefront pushing a lot of these
collectivist policies are not are are in
in a sort of cocoon a political
correctness they're taking the path of
least resistance they're not used to
people pushing back they're not used to
people and you don't even have to do to
push back in a sort of angry mean way
any kind of objection to them especially
if you show your human side and really
put pressure on them can be effective
and I've seen this firsthand when the
school district that I live in they did
a critical race Theory thing under the
guise of so-called Unity day
um I you know the superintendent after I
shown a spotlight on it was like
effectively begging me to go and meet
them in person because they were
surprised at all the angry parents
responding so I went and I talked with
them and politely explained why parents
were so angry and gave them some options
and I think that you know this kind of
where you look at sort of the middle
managers uh in this system of all of
these groups that sort of are kind of at
the front they're not used to people
being angry they're used to social
pressure that's basically how they
became a leftist to begin with is
because of peer pressure going with the
flow they need to understand that there
is no flow anymore there is no go there
is no you know just go go along to get
along sort of thing where you can run in
this little Suburban mom group and
everybody's going to agree with you you
have to to make sure that you understand
they need to see you as a person you
need to look them in the eye and so that
you don't agree with them and you need
to you know just show show them that
that they're hurting people with these
policies and that they're causing real
damage to this country and they're
people who are suffering and that you
know they may believe they have good
intentions but nobody ever really
explains to them the the human cost like
we saw with the with the North Carolina
uh restaurant owner there's a face to
these people who they're hurting there
is a flow that people can go with and it
leads to a waterfall yep so the people
who are sitting back being like hey man
look I'm not going to fight the current
eventually they just go
well you could have turned around you
could have paddled against it you could
have grabbed a tree branch or done
something but people just said I don't I
don't want to rock the boat you know I
the captain seems know what he's doing
and the cliff is right there that's what
it feels like to me
no one the people who are who are
running this stuff in in these town
councils and these City board meetings
they have no idea what they're doing
they have no idea what's going on they
don't know what is or isn't because the
rules keep changing and then you have
people sitting there being like well you
know they'll do it I guess no you people
got to wake up and be responsible for
their own lives man there's a there's a
there's a substantial substantive lack
of personal responsibility among a lot
of Americans these days yeah and I just
I I think that right now what we're
seeing with this sort of information
landscape that we're all we're all kind
of immersed in and that you know we're
an independent Media or alternative
media and they're trying to change the
landscape to take away uh our
opportunities to reach these people and
to organize them and you know I've been
trying to organize people to have
political pushback since the Tea Party
Movement into 2010.
um you know these sort of uh these sort
of organic Grassroots sort of
organization that we need to do
um that's that's that can be successful
and it can work but you have to get out
and you have to
you know make sure that you're very
visible I mean in New York they recently
had a protest against the the coveted
mandates and the uh in the in the
passports and they and they made a real
show to force but it's just glaring how
that's not really the case in this
country
um it's kind of um surprising to me it's
kind of a letdown that we're not really
getting out in force
um so I just want to encourage people to
really start using those networks that
they built up over the years and start
you know don't be afraid to go out and
organize and to do things the worst
thing they can do is is try to force you
to get home and if you do or try to
force you to go home or disperse for not
having an ordinance or having a petition
then
get it on video send it to influencers
make it known that there is real
authoritarianism Behind These policies
and make them make people understand
that these are authoritarians they can't
hide behind I think there's going to be
a a big wake-up call for a lot of people
now with the mandates NBC News ran this
article saying that vaccine mandates
will hurt corporations that are trying
to hire because a lot of people are
going to be like wait what I have to do
what you know we talk about this
restaurant this guy's not political he
doesn't know what's going on he's like I
don't want to be involved right how many
people were ignoring all of this being
like what we don't go outside we wear a
mask okay whatever you had uh who is it
Bill Burr the comedian where he was like
I turned the TV every two weeks and then
you know they tell me to wear a mask
I'll wear it whatever you had Ethan
Klein from H3 saying you just go to the
CDC and they tell you what to do you got
to think about it these are the people
we're going to wake up one day when they
go to work and they're gonna be like oh
did you get your your vaccine and
they're going to be like wait for my
what you have to do that yeah otherwise
you're fired and they're going to be
like
hold on a minute because there's a big
line between wearing a mask and getting
something injected into you again you
know you go to your doctor the problem
is some people might have okay and and I
looked up the pronunciation uh Guillain
Barson
no it is not Gian I looked it up and
talked to a french guy uh I can't
pronounce gilan Barre or Barre okay yeah
and or you can be you can if you say it
fast
syndrome all right and uh because it's
named after two guys that was their name
and because people keep telling me
different pronunciations for it so I
finally like just watched a video
talking about the scientist and I'm like
ah anyway uh if you have if you have an
underlying health condition and your
doctor recommends against it people are
going to wake up hard to like wait a
minute hold on a minute there was this
this band playing a show in Florida
where they said it's a thousand dollars
a ticket
but it's only 18 if you can prove you've
been vaccinated and so this one woman
gave an interview where she was like my
doctor recommended against the vaccine
and I can't go to the show but rich
people can that's going to be the thing
that kind of pulls people into what's
going on like all of a sudden now you've
got people who are going to go to shop
to work one day and they're gonna be
like you can't come back until you go to
your doctor and talk to them they're
going to be like really and now people
are going to be forced to ask questions
and engage well I saw I saw uh just this
week there was an Ohio Judge that sent a
man who had a possession of Fentanyl and
he was up in in front of the judge and
he violated his probation and one of the
terms of the probation that he was be
would be forced to take the vaccine uh
and one of the things that was
interesting about that is the judge
admitted I'm not a doctor and he's
supposedly just referred to the cdc's
order and that he had to wear a mask and
all of this stuff the CDC is de facto
acting as some extra legal actor in in
our uh you know in our high policy
process but they are just ultimately
bureaucrats and not only can they be
wrong they have been wrong multiple
times whether it's surface contaminants
or viral load after getting the vaccine
and and translate it just goes on and on
bouchi recognizes that you know he says
the science changed that the science
doesn't change your understanding of the
science change because you were not
making it according to the empirical
evidence that is right I think I think
the the science changes the problem is
in an emergency situation they're making
recommendations off of incomplete
information so they're like here's what
we know so so fauci said this this is
actually what fauci said that at first
they said Don't wear masks then they
found out asymptomatic people were
spreading it and said okay now wear
masks so they were still in the process
of trying to figure out what's going on
and then they said it was aerosolized
and and instead of just and and so you
know and so a mask is not going to have
any effect it's short of an n95
potentially that in a in a setting I'll
tell you the issue I have with like with
the with the establishment with YouTube
on this one is celebrities can come out
and tell you go and do it you can't come
out and say don't right right and the
argument is well the CDC is advising for
these things hold on even okay so I I I
I I think I shouldn't recommend anything
at all I think you should talk to a
medical professional you know somebody
who actually knows I don't want to get
sued if I give someone medical advice is
bad I don't want to get sued if I give
Financial advice that's bad I don't
think celebrities are in a place to
decide what someone should be doing with
with their with their health because
they may have like a Pete Parada
formerly of The Offspring gilan Bahrain
syndrome probably however Johnson and so
anyway what ends up happening is you see
all these celebrities telling people to
do something
I think because of that blind zealotry
vaccine zealotry you'll end up with more
reports in the Vera system people who
are adversely impacted because they
should have gone to a doctor and then
said to them like oh I have this that or
otherwise the doctor might have been
like oh okay for that reason I say no so
there's probably a small percentage of
people I do think the vaccines are
overwhelmingly safe I think it's fine
but I ultimately think
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna tell an
individual to ignore their doctor like a
celebrity would that to me is a problem
if you want to tell someone to go to
their I even I even had establishment
Democrat types attacking me as anti-vaxx
for saying please go to your doctor I
was on Twitter and I was like celebrity
should not be encouraging people they
should be encouraging them go to their
doctor and people were like you're an
anti-vaxxer I'm like what I really liked
what Dr Drew said the other day in this
sort of a you know mini viral rant that
he had about this that that when he was
a doctor and he was treating his
patients the CDC was like some kind of
footnote that you know okay oh the CDC
says that the who said that's great it's
like goes in the file of things then you
just don't pay attention to it very much
unless it's a headliner sort of thing of
you know a drug problem or something
like this it wasn't
The Authority body that you took orders
from uh no if you have your license to
practice medicine you treat people on an
individual patient basis and you know
all the statistics you know the health
factors the risk factors you and you
know I mean you don't need the CDC to
tell you these things you need them to
publish them uh and sure sure there
might be some guidance there but it's
kind of like in The Helpful suggestions
thing and a doctor can be go thank you
thank you very much for your opinion but
that's fine I've got it it's the
authoritarian creep right it was Trump
Trump's a hypochondriac and he gave full
power to the CDC and fauci just
completely elevated it all and I was
like it's a horrible Global pandemic
and then he gave it up Trump definitely
get deserves some criticism for what
you're saying he he has a germaphobe I
hear oh yeah absolutely the handshakes
for a long time he did and that's why
you want to shake people here I was told
that he only eats fast food because it's
uh you can walk in order it and it's
already pre-made and there's a there's a
concern about if he orders it to order
someone will do something to it well no
wonder he got used to the ketchup that
he puts on a steak I could think of
maybe the only exception but did you you
could be right well I love the ketchup
and steak story do you remember this one
do you guys remember this one it's
really really good and I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring it back back up
because we haven't said in a long time
it was a big report about Trump having
this very fancy like dry aged steak well
done with ketchup
and the media insulted him and ridiculed
him and said he was so uncouth and oh he
doesn't even know how to eat steak oh
this guy's ridiculous meanwhile working
class union guy in the midwest was
sitting there eating his well done
T-Bone with ketchup gone
but that's how I like my steak
see when I was growing up we had the
garbage stakes from the from the local
supermarket you don't cook those rare
you got to cook them through because
they're not good steaks and then you
schlop ketchup on them so you do my dad
would always be like you know that's an
insult right it's like I make my steaks
good but we had good steaks when I was
kid we weren't always eating bad steaks
but when we would it's like you cook it
through Donald Trump does that it's
relatable to Working Class People who
can't afford the filet mignon to the
rich people they're laughing medium rare
a little garlic and salt what's he doing
what what a nut just shows you how the
establishment hates the little guy
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time